vrai à ton jeune âge tu dois devoir
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 15 mars voici le programme
de ce soir au coeur de l'actualité cette
huitième journée de mobilisation contre
la réforme des retraites alors que le
texte pourrait être adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale en fin de semaine
la contestation est toujours bien
présente dans les Yvelines ce matin un
rassemblement devant la sous-préfecture
de Mantes-la-Jolie était organisée par
la CGT une autre se tenait également à
Versailles nous ferons le point avec nos
journalistes Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
et Céline Charles du sport également
dans votre 7 8 il a fait ses armes à
Guyancourt et il est aujourd'hui le
meilleur pilote du monde de karting à
seulement 14 ans jimmelia aussi entre la
cinquième et la deuxième place depuis le
début de la saison il s'envole bientôt
pour disputer le championnat d'Europe en
Espagne son rêve devenir un champion de
Formule 1 se prodige du volant sera avec
nous ce soir en plateau et enfin une
information insolite à
Fontenay-le-Fleury dans les Yvelines
existe une école pour apprendre à
marcher avec des chaussures à talons
alors si vous aussi vous êtes toujours
demandé comment faire pour ne pas tomber
et surtout pour ne pas avoir mal aux
pieds restez bien avec nous la
fondatrice de la talon Academy et met un
Berne nous donnera à tous ces précieux
conseils elle est notre invité et avec
nous en plateau ce soir clair chérie
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes la mère
de Cernay-la-Ville et Samedi dernier
vous avez organisé une visite
théâtralisée au Petit Moulin des Vaux de
Cernay c'était en collaboration avec le
bazar culturel un théâtre social
itinérant et pour cette visite
théâtralisée vous avez réuni des jeunes
cernésiens des jeunes adolescents avec
des résidents du centre d'hébergement
d'urgence de demandeurs d'asile à Bonnel
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer comment est née cette
initiative d'où elle vient alors cette
initiative en fait elle vient d'une part
du fait que la mairie de Cernay a repris
la gestion du Petit Moulin qui est un
centre d'interprétation qui appartient
au département et qui était fermé depuis
trois ans et donc nous avons repris ce
musée avec le financement du département
sur un projet qui s'appelle faire
patrimoine ensemble donc valoriser le
patrimoine mais ensemble en tissant du
lien et en mettant en relation des
publics qui ne sont pas amenés forcément
à se rencontrer et donc ça c'était la
première chose et la deuxième chose
c'est que Alex à d'argent avec le bazar
culturel est venu nous trouver pour nous
proposer des projets et on s'est dit que
c'était vraiment l'occasion donc de le
le faire
voilà travailler avec des publics
d'origine différente et puis faire un
projet à cet endroit là et donc on aura
l'occasion d'en parler plus en détail
justement avec Alex à d'argent le
coordinateur du bazar culturel alors si
vous avez bien suivi ce soir on va
parler de sport de karting mais aussi de
taekwondo je vous le disais bonsoir Yann
Burel vous êtes le président de l'école
de taekwondo de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et vous
revenez tout juste de Las Vegas aux
Etats-Unis parce que 6 de vos sportifs
ont participé à l'US Open ce week-end le
week-end dernier avec une médaille d'or
et deux médailles de bronze vous revenez
ravis contents je suppose tout à fait
même si sur 6 athlètes on a toujours
l'espoir de ramener un maximum de
médailles mais on est satisfait du bilan
de cette compétition en effet donc on
reviendra plus en détail sur les
prestations de Oumaima alassak Mehdi el
Hazard et Khalida Haddad ils sont en
plateau tout à l'heure avec nous pour
parler de leur parcours mais pour le
moment nous sommes avec aussi deux
journalistes de la rédaction de TV 78
c'est Lynn Charles Régina rage bonsoir
bonsoir alors Céline comme d'habitude le
mercredi vous nous présenter les sorties
ciné à ne pas manquer durant la semaine
est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire un
petit teasing bien sûr alors on parlera
d'une comédie noire d'un biopic sur
Emily Brontë d'un film français porté
par Alexandra Lamy donc ce sera enfin
d'émission restez bien avec nous Régine
rallès vous vous allez nous présenter
les informations du jour à retenir dans
les Yvelines mais avant on va jeter un
coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
le printemps s'installe peu à peu dans
les Yvelines demain matin le ciel sera
voilé mais ensoleillé sur l'ensemble du
département au niveau des températures
il fera doux avec 7 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles Rambouillet
et Houdan dans l'après-midi le temps
sera toujours sec et ensoleillé côté
température le thermomètre montera à 15
degrés à Mantes au lit et 16 degrés à
Versailles Rambouillet et Houdan et
demain nous fêterons la sainte Bénédicte
le point maintenant sur les informations
du jour dans les Yvelines
et c'est avec vous Régina ralech on
commence par cette information du jour à
ne pas manquer on fait un point sur la
grève tout à fait Mathilde dans cette
huitième journée de mobilisation contre
la réforme des retraites le service des
trains et des RER a été perturbé et
selon Axel personne secrétaire général
CGT cheminots de Trappes il fallait
compter la moitié des trains supprimés
sur la ligne N et un tiers des trains
supprimés sur la ligne C du côté de
l'éducation à l'échelle de l'académie de
Versailles 5% des enseignants du collège
se sont déclarés en grève et ils étaient
14% dans les lycées et du côté des
universités des étudiants opposés à la
réforme des retraites ont bloqué deux
bâtiments à l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines et on poursuit
ses informations du jour avec des jobs
datings qui sont prévus dans les
prochains jours tout à fait vendredi 17
mars un rendez-vous se tiendra au centre
commercial de Westfield Vélizy 2 à
Vélizy-Villacoublay l'événement est
destiné à tout public dans la vente et
la restauration il y aura 75 offres qui
seront à pourvoir mais avant ça jeudi de
14h à 16h à Versailles les rendez-vous
de l'emploi organise un job dating
destiné cette fois-ci au Seigneur de
plus de 45 ans l'événement se tiendra à
l'Hôtel de Ville à Versailles et le but
est de mettre en avant des profils
expérimentés auprès d'entreprises
publics privées d'associations mais
aussi de cabinets de management et enfin
hier matin à Noisy-le-Roi des
interpellations ont été conduites par la
gendarmerie nationale tout à fait deux
individus ont été auditionnés ils sont
suspectés d'avoir cambriolé le domicile
du joueur du PSG presnel kimpembe le 25
novembre 2022 le préjudice total est
estimé à environ 5000 euros et bien
merci beaucoup Régine rallès pour ces
informations et puis comme d'habitude si
vous aussi vous voyez une information
une image qui vous a marqué près de chez
vous n'hésitez pas à nous la partager en
utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news au cœur de
l'actualité également vous en parler à
l'instant Régine 7 8e journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites alors que le texte pourrait
éteindre cette semaine par l'Assemblée
nationale la contestation est toujours
bien présente dans les Yvelines ce matin
la CGT des Yvelines a organisé une
manifestation à Versailles syndicat
agriculteurs et hommes politiques sont
partis de la gare de chantier pour se
rendre au château de Versailles les
précisions de Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
et Céline Charles
à la retraite Versailles s'est fait
entendre aujourd'hui à l'occasion de la
8ème journée de mobilisation contre les
réformes des retraites après une
première manifestation le 16 février
dernier les syndicats se sont donnés
rendez-vous une seconde fois devant la
gare de Versailles-Chantiers on va aller
manifester jusqu'au gris du château avec
notre détermination et notre dignité de
travailleurs pour aller montrer qu'on
ira jusqu'au bout qu'il vote qu'il vote
pas 49-3 ou pas nous ne sommes pas
prisonniers de l'agenda parlementaire
notre agenda c'est l'intérêt des
travailleurs au total 350 personnes se
sont mobilisées une vingtaine
d'agriculteurs étaient présents à leur
côté le MODEF le mouvement de défense
des exploitants familiaux et la
Confédération paysanne ont distribué
gratuitement deux tonnes de nourriture
aux manifestants objectifs faire preuve
de solidarité pour leur permettre
d'aller jusqu'au bout du combat montrer
que les travailleurs de la terre que
sont les petits moyens paysans mènent le
même combat que les salariés de France
pour effectivement avoir à la fois une
recette une retraite descente mais une
retraite à 60 ans qui sont largement
mérités après 40 ou 45 ans de travail
pour soutenir le cortège plusieurs
hommes politiques ont également fait le
déplacement
le Conseil d'orientation des retraites
le fameux corps ce gouvernement ferait
mieux d'écouter les corps de ces hommes
et de ses femmes abîmées par des années
des années de travail sur les chaînes
d'ateliers ou dans les champs c'est un
beau symbole de se retrouver ici à
Versailles là où la monarchie a été
abolie là où la République est née et
puis c'est le rassemblement des paysans
des Métallos des cheminots des
énergéticiens ce qui nous nourrissent
comme ceux qui font tourner l'industrie
font retirer cette réforme exiger de
tous les travailleurs et travailleuses
qu'il fasse deux ans de plus c'est
insupportable les gens ont des métiers
difficiles ou des métiers pénibles pour
la plupart des gens ce sera tout
simplement pas possible de travailler
deux années de plus la commission mixte
paritaire c'est quant à elle accordait
cet après-midi sur le report de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite à 64 ans
le texte doit encore être soumis jeudi
au vote du Sénat et de l'Assemblée
nationale
on en parlait en début d'émission le
bazar culturel théâtre social itinérant
et la mairie de Cernay-la-Ville ont mis
en place un projet culturel innovant au
sein du Petit Moulin des vaux-de-cernée
samedi dernier des jeunes de la commune
ont présenté une visite théâtralisée
avec des résidents du centre
d'hébergement d'urgence pour demandeurs
d'asile à Bonnelles pour en parler avec
nous claire chéri la mère de
Cernay-la-Ville et Alex Adam le
coordinateur du bazar culturel bonsoir
bonsoir alors en début d'émission claire
chéri vous nous avez un petit peu
expliqué d'où est venu cette initiative
maintenant quel est quel a été
l'objectif de ce projet culturel de
cette visite théâtralisée
déjà juste une précision les jeunes qui
ont participé sont des jeunes de Cernay
mais aussi des jeunes de la vallée
puisque le lycée de la vallée a été un
peu un relais pour nous pour
trouver des jeunes qui étaient
intéressés et donc ça a permis aussi
d'étendre d'ouvrir un peu les portes du
village aux jeunes des villes ou village
voisin de Cernay-la-Ville et de la
Vallée de Chevreuse
et donc l'objectif est bien évidemment
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure c'était
de tisser du lien et de permettre à des
personnes donc les réfugiés du centre de
Bonnel et les jeunes de la vallée
d'entrer en contact et de réaliser un
projet culturel un projet
qui leur permettent ensuite une certaine
forme d'expression théâtrale et puis du
coup de à travers ça à la fois de tisser
du lien mais aussi de raconter une
histoire et donc d'aller chercher un peu
au fond d'eux des choses importantes à
partager aussi avec le public qui est
venu ce jour-là et justement pour
rebondir à ce que vous disiez vous aviez
réussi à mobiliser des jeunes grâce aux
établissements scolaires comment est-ce
que vous aviez mobilisé justement ces
réfugiés comment est-ce que sont portés
volontaires ou comment ça s'est passé
alors qu'en fait quand on a obtenu le la
subvention du département en fait il
fallait justement avoir des partenaires
et donc nous nous sommes associés avec
une association qui s'appelle solidarité
accompagnement pour les migrants et qui
travaillent qui avec les réfugiés de
Bonnel et donc ils ont été notre notre
relais en fait auprès des migrants et
donc eux ils ont présenté le projet Alex
aussi est allé pour leur présenter le
projet et les personnes qui étaient
enthousiastes à l'idée de ce projet donc
sont venus ce jour-là ces journaux
l'idée c'était de les rencontrer en fait
en amont des répétitions on a demandé
stage de théâtre pour que des gens se
connaissent parce que la relation de
confiance c'est aussi très importante
que ce soit avec les jeunes comme avec
les migrants d'ailleurs il y a pas de il
y a pas de différence là dessus et donc
le fait on se connaisse déjà c'était
à facilité en fait le travail qu'on a pu
faire parce que du coup ils sont venus
aussi non seulement pour faire du
théâtre mais aussi pour qu'on passe un
moment ensemble voilà et juste par
rapport aux objectifs sur ce que disait
claire j'ajouterai aussi que dans dans
un processus de médiation culturelle
très souvent nous on a le public cible
là en l'occurrence ça aurait pu être les
migrants et donc très souvent on va
monter une action à destination de ce
public et c'est eux qui vont venir on va
essayer de leur rendre accessible un
patrimoine là l'idée c'est un petit peu
de prendre le parti inverse c'est à dire
on leur met le patrimoine à disposition
donc là en l'occurrence c'était le petit
moulin et donc on construit la visite
avec eux donc ce n'est plus le public
auquel on va destiné une visite mais
c'est eux qui vont s'approprier le
monument à leur façon et en faire
quelque chose et le fait de le faire en
plus avec des jeunes bah évidemment ça
crée du lien et ça ça donne une approche
qui est totalement différente de ce
qu'on peut voir traditionnel et
justement
être réalisé samedi dernier je vous
propose de regarder le reportage et on
continue d'en parler juste après
une visite pas comme les autres samedi
11 mars les Yvelinois de passage au
Petit Moulin des voies de Cernay ont pu
découvrir le bâtiment d'une manière
originale
le bazar culturel théâtre social
itinérant a réalisé une visite
théâtralisée sur le thème du voyage et
de l'identité avec des jeunes cernésiens
et des résidents du centre d'hébergement
d'urgence pour demandeurs d'asile de
bonnet c'était vraiment de créer du
mélange entre les cultures et surtout de
trouver un
instant de partage entre chacun on a
tous vécu des événements à un moment qui
ont marqué notre vie quel que soit nos
parcours quel que soit l'endroit où l'on
se trouve la langue qu'on parle et donc
l'idée c'était de retrouver du commun à
partir de ça mais je vous raconterai
aussi mon histoire
2021 je vis en Colombie j'ai étudié
administration publique Louisa Lopez et
colombienne arrivait en France en
janvier 2022 elle fait partie des cinq
migrants participants à ce projet
culturel j'ai trop que c'est vraiment
l'important c'est super bien parce que
les spectacles aussi nous montre comment
c'est la réalité des différentes
personnes qui habitent des différents
lieux de ces histoires c'est totalement
différent et aujourd'hui on peut trouver
tout le monde ici pour nous compter
cette histoire
et pour les aider à compter ces
histoires 5 jeunes de la commune de
Cernay qui ont bien voulu s'ouvrir aux
cultures étrangères
d'autres personnes que potentiellement
je le connaissais pas je sais pas
comment ça se passe c'est très bien
passé j'ai passé une très bonne semaine
avec eux le Centre d'hébergement de
demandeurs d'asile de Bonnelles
accueille une centaine de réfugiés
au-delà de l'apprentissage de la langue
française de nombreuses activités sont
mises en place pour les sortir de leur
quotidien comme cette visite
théâtralisée au Petit Moulin des Vaux de
Cernay
alors comme on a pu le voir dans le
reportage on a cette participante Louisa
Lopez qui est colombienne elle parle
français et ce qu'il y a eu une barrière
aussi du langage avec les autres
personnes avec qui vous avez pu
travailler ah oui juste une petite
précision Louisa en fait travaille
travaille au Petit Moulin elle fait pas
partie du groupe de migrants donc elle a
cette particularité en plus mais alors
oui sur la barrière de la langue bon on
a travaillé beaucoup avec la gestuelle
et puis en fait au bout d'un moment il y
a un langage commun qui s'est créé aussi
et puis ce qui a été compliqué au départ
à la fois pour moi comme pour eux ça a
été de se dire les choses clairement et
puis moi au début je j'osais peut-être
pas leur
demander si s'ils avaient bien compris
etc et puis après au bout d'un moment ça
se faisait assez naturellement quand je
disais tu as compris il me disait non
prenait et puis voilà quoi et comment
est-ce que vous avez réussi à tisser du
lien entre bah c'est réfugiés et ces
jeunes adolescents ça ça s'est fait
vraiment au fur et à mesure ouais ouais
ça a été un long parcours finalement on
a eu que quatre jours de répétition donc
c'est passé quand même assez vite mais
voilà le premier jour a servi aussi
beaucoup à faire connaissance et après
petit à petit des rapports se sont
tissés de manière très très timide au
départ et puis voilà peu à peu quand on
a commencé à monter le spectacle aussi
ça a vraiment servi à faire du lien
parce que au départ il faisait des impro
un peu chacun de son côté et puis quand
on a commencé vraiment à travailler
ensemble à faire du lien entre les
scènes etc là quelque part ils étaient
obligés de parler les uns avec les
autres et puis en fait ça s'est fait
quasiment naturellement quoi des deux
côtés et on l'entend un petit peu dans
dans le reportage alors des deux côtés
ils entirent des bénéfices une
expérience positive mais est-ce que vous
avez eu aussi d'autres retours enfin
est-ce que vous avez pu échanger avec
eux sur sur ce projet culturel qu'est-ce
qu'ils en ont pensé
non alors avec les migrants pas
directement j'ai changé avec des
personnes de l'association qui m'ont dit
que les retours étaient plutôt positifs
et enfin déjà on le voit en termes de
date parce que le stage on a réalisé fin
février la représentation elle a eu lieu
le 11 mars et du coup il y a quand même
un laps de temps et quand on travaille
avec des publics qui sont divulnérables
c'est vrai que le rapport au temps est
pas tout à fait le même et donc il
pourrait y avoir de la perte entre
guillemets là faut savoir que sur le
stage il y a eu quand même un noyau très
solide il y en a qui sont venus les
quatre jours sur la représentation ils
se sont pas démobilisés non plus donc il
y a eu un vrai enfin voilà ils étaient
vraiment vraiment très investis dans ce
projet quoi et Claire chéri est-ce que
on peut s'attendre à une suite ou est-ce
que il y aura un autre projet culturel
comme comme celui-ci l'année prochaine
peut-être alors certainement en tout cas
nous on y est favorable parce que c'est
vrai que le travail avec Alex a été tout
à fait bénéfique là il l'a rappelé que
le stage n'a duré que quatre jours donc
il y a eu un peu de travail en amont
pour mobiliser
les jeunes et les migrants mais en fait
il a réussi parce qu'il sait ça il sait
faire ça très bien
à les investir très très vite dans le
projet et donc ils nous ont restitués
samedi dernier un projet qui était
vraiment de qualité moi j'ai trouvé tout
à fait bouleversant et très et voilà
émouvant chacun y a mis un peu ses
tripes sur la table donc c'est ça aussi
qui fait que les retours sont positifs
parce que vraiment chacun a vécu ce
moment de façon très intense et donc
nous on est fait on serait ravis de
continuer à travailler avec Alex sur
d'autres d'autres types de projets à
destination de ce public là ou d'autres
en tout cas on a plein de projets pour
le petit moulin dans les mois à venir et
on aura peut-être l'occasion d'en parler
un peu plus tard merci à vous deux
d'avoir accepté notre invitation on va
passer à un tout autre sujet à présent
lutter contre le gaspillage alimentaire
tout en valorisant la réinsertion
professionnelle c'est le but de pierre
rouge et de une épouse en mars 2021 elle
crée l'association bon et rebond à
Rambouillet Gabriel Gontier et Grégory
canalet ont visité les cuisines de
l'association regardez permettre à des
personnes éloignées de l'emploi de se
réinsérer dans la société grâce à la
transformation alimentaire de fruits et
légumes vendus c'est l'ambition de
l'association bon et rebond à
Rambouillet cet après-midi Xavier
bénévole au sein de l'association
égyptie en insertion sont en pleine
conception d'une nouvelle recette comme
caramel le nom en fait de vent sera vive
la récré
le test dames il a été fait 100 pectine
et là on se rend compte en fait que
c'est que c'est vraiment trop liquide
donc du coup j'ai ajusté mais j'ai mis
j'ai mis à vue de nez comme ça c'est
d'expérience j'ai mis
0,4%, ça fait 63 g de pectine au travers
de la cuisine c'est un véritable moment
de partage que permet l'association et
un moyen de se réinsérer dans la vie
professionnelle tu pourras faire goûter
à tes enfants
au début je vous promets c'était un peu
compliqué mais voilà
j'ai repris le rythme et c'est bon là je
suis très bien tout le monde s'entend
bien tout le monde oui oui il y a pas de
souci aucun problème après la
préparation place à la mise en pot par
Gypsy et Nabil également en insertion
comme toujours au sein de l'association
le travail se fait en équipe donc là on
les contrôle c'est bien fermé à
l'origine de ce projet pierre rouge le
directeur de l'association qui au
travers d'une activité anti-gaspillage a
réussi à allier la formation à la
réinsertion les personnes en insertion
sont donc des personnes très éloignées
de l'emploi ou en suppression handicap
sont des gens qu'on embauche 28 heures
par semaine et qui donc reprennent un
peu contact avec le travail donc arrivé
à un horaire précis avoir des collègues
de travail avoir un chef qui va vous
donner des consignes des ordres qu'il
faut entendre et une progression
régulière de l'apprentissage qui est
qui est à expérimenté un apprentissage
appuyé par les bénévoles de
l'association qui jouent un rôle de
relais c'est le cas de Xavier bénévole
et trésorier qui s'est lancé dans
l'aventure bon et rebond des sacréation
tout est dans le dans le nom de
l'association c'est bon ce qu'on fait
pour moi je suis souvent assez fier en
fait de ce qu'on sort en fait comme
comme produit de nos ateliers et puis le
rebond c'est l'essence du du projet une
entreprise sociale solidaire et
familiale qui porte déjà ses fruits
chaque jour ce sont près de 150 pots qui
sont créés par les personnes en
insertion et par les bénévoles depuis
septembre 2021 ce sont 21000 pots qui
ont été vendus
allez on ouvre à présent une page sport
et on commence par du Taekwondo sea
sportif de l'école de taekwondo de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ont participé
à l'US Open de Las Vegas le week-end
dernier ils sont trois à être présents
avec nous ce soir en plateau avec leur
coach leur président de l'école de
taekwondo il y a une Burel et on est
aussi du coup avec
umaima alassac bonsoir bonsoir alors
vous avez eu la médaille d'or dans la
catégorie cadette féminine moins 44 kg
mais dit elle Azar bonsoir alors vous
vous avez eu la médaille de bronze dans
la catégorie cadet masculin moins 53 kg
et enfin Khalida Haddad bonsoir vous
avez remporté la médaille de bronze dans
la catégorie senior féminine moins 67 kg
alors première question à tous les trois
ça s'est plutôt bien passé la
compétition sur place comment est-ce que
vous l'avez vécu franchement ouais c'est
bien passé on était très bien préparé
mais ça aurait pu se passer mieux mais
c'est très bien passé
c'était la première fois que vous alliez
aussi loin pour une compétition pour ma
part c'est la deuxième fois la première
elle avait eu à Miami après c'est
toujours c'est un peu un rêve de
combattre là-bas c'est Las Vegas c'est
ça fait rêver et puis ça c'est bien
passé au début le décalage avec avec des
caries c'était compliqué mais du coup on
s'est vite adapté et puis voilà et pour
vous deux c'était la première fois ça
fait la première fois les États-Unis
après ça fait plaisir première fois aux
États-Unis la médaille ça fait plaisir
moi aussi c'était la première fois
c'était c'est bien passé et donc c'est
un rêve pour vous en tant que jeune je
suppose de voyager et de et de faire son
sport avec passion le taekwondo
Yann Burel du coup je vous en parlait
aussi en début d'émission c'est une
fierté pour vous je suppose comment
est-ce que ça s'est passé concrètement
sur place c'est pas la première fois que
que vous avez des compétitions de ce
genre à l'international c'est c'est une
école qui devient de plus en plus connue
dans le secteur oui ou alors on a été
plusieurs fois meilleurs clubs de France
cadet junior chez les jeunes donc on a
déjà une reconnaissance nationale
importante les jeunes que vous avez ici
ont déjà fait des médailles nationales
sur la plus haute marche donc ce sont
pas des débutants on envoie vraiment les
livres du club ils sont tous athlètes de
haut niveau ils ont fait une
acclimatation quelques jours à Los
Angeles où on connaissait un coach
sportif qui les a accompagnés quelques
jours pour l'adaptation avant de se
diriger vers Las Vegas donc ils ont déjà
fait quelques compétitions
internationales que ça soit avec le club
ou en équipe nationale donc qui sont
déjà un peu habitués quand même aux
compétitions internationales ils seront
à nouveau en Belgique ce week-end pour
participer à un open puisque le but
c'est grappiller des points dans le dans
le classement mondial et éventuellement
celui-ci
au niveau de du classement olympique et
pouvoir participer aux Jeux Olympiques
il y a d'autres grandes échéances
échéances cette année pour eux
oui alors il y a encore des championnats
championnats du monde qui seront à venir
pour les pour les plus jeunes et après
il y a des Open internationaux auxquels
ils vont participer oui alors on va
revenir un petit peu sur vos trois
parcours à l'US Open à Las Vegas Oumaima
à la SEC vous avez enchaîné quatre tours
en gagnant vos quatre rounds et vous
avez aussi remporte vous l'avez aussi
remporté contre la numéro une américaine
à domicile aux Etats-Unis on peut dire
que vous avez survolé cette compétition
oui ça a été très dur sur les débuts de
compétition et après sur les suivants
combats c'était plus facile c'était plus
facile de A à Z vous avez trouvé ça
difficile où il y a quand même eu des
complications il y a eu beaucoup de
complications avec le stress et tout
mais après ça allait mieux mais comment
est-ce que vous vous préparez il y a une
préparation physique mais une
préparation aussi mentale je suppose oui
comment comment est-ce que ça se passe
c'est plus dans les entraînements et
tout genre par exemple sur la piste ou
concours et à l'entraînement
Mehdi de votre côté c'était un peu plus
compliqué j'ai cru comprendre vous avez
bataillé jusqu'au bout pour obtenir
cette médaille de bronze et vous l'avez
remporté vous l'avez bien mérité
qu'est-ce qui était compliqué pour vous
c'était des concurrents forts face à
vous c'est un adversaire très fort avec
la fatigue de la journée le combat il
s'est ça a été très tard dans le soir
donc avec la fatigue de la journée mes
deux tours juste avant c'était très dur
et c'est pas grave
vous avez quand même remporté
une belle médaille Yann Burel la
concurrence c'était était rude lors de
cette US Open concurrence très rude il y
avait des champions des numéros en
mondiaux
Oumaima elle a battu une fille qui était
troisième ou Championnat du Monde ou
même a aussi fini troisième au
championnat du monde mais elle a donc su
battre une adversaire qu'elle avait sur
le podium donc ils ont vraiment eu ils
ont su élever leur niveau de performance
raida aussi enseignant il y avait un
niveau très élevé avec des champions du
monde des coréennes donc c'était
vraiment c'était vraiment une
compétition très relevée et justement
comment ça s'est passé pour vous
les adversaires étaient avaient un
niveau très élevé comment est-ce que ça
s'est passé pour vous la compétition
c'est vrai que la catégorie enfin ma
catégorie poids c'était enfin il y avait
un niveau très élevé il y avait des
notamment la meilleure à tête américaine
et puis bah les deux premiers combats ça
a été difficile parce que c'était des
combattants passés agressifs et elles
envoyaient mais ça c'est bien passé
après en finale j'avais j'ai rencontré
une une athlète coréenne que j'avais
déjà eu auparavant j'avais perdu contre
elle mais j'ai pas perdu de la même
façon c'était une défaite sur le fil
j'ai perdu au dernier round à égalité
mais c'est elle qui avait l'avantage
vous pensez aux Jeux Olympiques
peut-être pas à ceux de Paris mais
pourquoi pas d'ailleurs mais est-ce que
vous pensez à cette échéance les Jeux
Olympiques plus tard
et puis aussi c'est le projet Mehdi
omaima pareil
de quoi on fait tout pour pour y arriver
un jour et vous Yann Burel c'est aussi
un rêve bien sûr c'est le rêve de tout
coach et de devoir ces jeunes parvenir à
participer aux rêves olympiques et
pourquoi pas y ramener une médaille donc
pour pour Paris ça va être un peu juste
pour eux ralidal est encore en course
elle a une adversaire très dure dans la
catégorie au niveau national mais voilà
tout est encore possible à un peu plus à
500 jours maintenant des Jeux Olympiques
et bien merci en tout cas à vous quatre
d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et d'avoir partagé votre
expérience en plateau on va vous laisser
quitter le plateau tranquillement et on
va parler de karting à présent va
accueillir dans quelques instants Jimmy
Elias et son entraîneur Julien abélie en
2017 il était venu sur notre plateau
pour Interview Mickaël et le midoro
notre journaliste sportif lui avait
demandé quel était son rêve on écoute
l'extrait tout de suite Jimmy quelle est
la prochaine étape pour toi
déjà être champion du monde dans le
quartier et après être en Formule 1
alors tu es fan je crois de Lewis
Hamilton et
voilà le rêve est concrétisé aujourd'hui
Jimmy Elias c'est le nouveau numéro 1
mondial sur l'international kurting
ranking list a tout juste 14 ans ce
classement a été mis en place cette
année par la Fédération Internationale
de l'Automobile du melias et récompensé
pour sa rapidité et sa régularité depuis
le début de la saison il ne se classe
pas en dessous de la cinquième place
jimmelia et Julien abélie bonsoir à vous
deux alors Jimmy est-ce que tu as
d'autres objectifs après avoir
concrétisé ce premier objectif pour moi
le plus important là ça va être d'être
champion d'Europe et champion du monde
pour marquer des gros points pour la
suite de ma carrière et peut-être la
Formule 1 aussi la Formule 1 bah ça
c'est mon premier objectif à faire mais
va falloir attendre un peu et donc tu es
le nouveau numéro 1 mondial dans la
catégorie élite la plus élevé alors que
tu que tu y es depuis novembre dernier
on peut dire que c'est une ascension
fulgurante je viens avec autant de
résultats aussi rapidement de 10000 mais
il s'est vite adapté à la catégorie il a
su course après course progresser et
maintenir son niveau au sommet comment
est-ce que vous expliquez
les talentueux il a une bonne équipe il
se prépare bien et puis on va dire qui
est très motivé et que chaque week-end
il essaie de se remettre en question et
de s'améliorer weekend après weekend
justement il y a des compétences des
qualités à avoir absolument pour
une grosse partie un matin il reste
encore des quelques lacunes à développer
mais il reste encore très jeune c'est le
plus jeune de la catégorie et on lui
demande déjà beaucoup donc à 14 ans il
demande de de faire ce que beaucoup de
pilotes professionnels font à 20 ans
donc voilà il démonte que il est
ultra performant ultra précoce qu'est ce
qu'il faudrait améliorer justement ce
montage Jimmy il y a beaucoup de choses
à améliorer notamment la préparation
physique mentale c'est ce que je bosse
avec Julien et je voulais le remercier
pour tout le travail qui fait pour moi
facilement vous êtes d'accord avec lui
quelles sont les pistes à améliorer
vous
[Musique]